moi ce que j'ai trouvé intéressant
c'était d'aller à la rencontre de gens
qui pensent différemment certains se
trompent et sont ridicule d'autres sont
parfois assez intéressants mais dans
tous les cas c'est des personnages
étranges et des historiens qui sont pas
universitaires qui sont pour la plupart
des des gens des allumer sceptiques des
paranoïa critiques vous voyez et c'est
je trouve ça facilement
Christophe bonsoir vous êtes journaliste
et historien et vous venez de publier et
si c'était la vérité en quête sur les
délires de l'histoire aux éditions Viber
exactement
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la vérité est ailleurs alors on commence
avec Hitler évidemment bien sûr Hitler
serait mort au Brésil en 1984 il aurait
fui en Argentine en 1945 avec l'aide du
Vatican et ensuite il se serait installé
au Paraguay puis dans un village du Mato
Grosso au Brésil sous le nom d'Adolphe
Leipzig c'est vrai que le mec qui va se
planquer
le prénom Adolf à mon avis
il a gardé la moustache et à mon avis il
eut été judicieux qu'il la coupa
ceci étant il épouse là-bas une femme
noire qui s'appelle coutinga et un jour
une religieuse polonaise
croise Hitler dans l'hôpital de guyaba
dans les années 80 elle veut en parler
j'ai vu Hitler et ça hiérarchie lui dit
non parlait pas effectivement lui
interdire surtout me dit rien la vérité
c'est que beaucoup d'anciens nazis et de
collaborateurs même français ont été
protégés après la guerre je découvrent
par certains prêtres par certains
hiérards que d'église catholique alors
après on peut dire que ah bah du coup
ils ont protégé Hitler mais on voit pas
l'intérêt du Vatican non plus en même
temps
je me suiciderai pas dans le bunker
honnêtement toi tu es à sa place si
genre l'homme le plus puissant du monde
la vérité c'est qu'on a pas retrouvé les
restes ça a été brûlé bah on aurait pu
tout le monde voilà c'est vrai que le
fragment de crâne appartient à une femme
de 20 ans
ce n'est pas Hitler donc là il y a
évidemment une
énigme historique sur cette question
moi ce que j'ai trouvé intéressant
c'était d'aller à la rencontre de gens
qui pensent différemment certains se
trompent et sont ridicule d'autres sont
parfois assez intéressants mais dans
tous les cas c'est des personnages
étranges et des historiens qui sont pas
universitaires qui sont pour la plupart
des des gens des allumer sceptiques des
paranoïa critiques et c'est je trouve ça
facilement l'homme n'a pas marché sur la
Lune je sais pas si vous le saviez mais
bon ce n'est jamais arrivé tout a été
filmé en studio par Stanley Kubrick
alors les arguments sont très forts
c'est à dire que le drapeau flotte alors
qu'il y a pas d'atmosphère il y a pas de
vent on voit pas d'étoiles alors que sur
la lune normalement on devrait voir des
étoiles il y a même un bout de
chewing-gum par terre qui a été oublié
par un assistant alors la script pardon
elle aurait pu faire son boulot et pire
encore il y a il y a un caillou par
terre et il y a le numéro du caillou oh
alors là excusez-moi mais vraiment il y
en a qui sont pas leur boule dans
l'équipe de kubrique
sauf que les fragments qu'ils ont
rapporté sont des pierres les pierres de
lune témoignent du fait qu'on est bien
euh quelque part j'aime pas trop qu'on
vous dites que c'est pas vrai
j'adore y croire
Elvis Presley n'est pas mort alors bien
sûr c'est vrai que le certificat de
décès d'Elvis Presley a été rédigé deux
mois après sa mort le corps est quand
même brillant
un mannequin de cire et alors quand même
plus fort deux heures après l'annonce de
la mort d'Elvis Presley il y a un billet
d'avion qui a été acheté pour Buenos
Aires toujours Buenos Aires
acheter sous le nom de John Barrows
voilà qui était le pseudo sous lequel
Elvis Presley réservé ses chambres de
toutes ses chambres d'hôtel tout il
faisait tout sur évidemment Presley
donc il n'est pas mort par contre Paul
McCartney que vous êtes allé voir en
concert il y a récemment lui est mort en
et dans la mythologie hindoue les morts
sont pieds nus c'est ça ça fait partie
des nombreux signes qui prouvent qu'il
est mort mais qui veut dire que depuis
1966 c'est un sosie qui le remplit
puisque ma carte neuf est toute sa
carrière depuis 66 c'est est-ce que le
rock est mort dans l'Europe a été créé
en laboratoire à l'Institut ta vie stock
au début des années 60 par des
chercheurs anglais qui voulaient
asservir la population mondiale donc ils
ont ils ont créé les Beatles et qui se
sont dit il y a une part du marché qui
nous échappe c'est les bad boys donc ils
ont créé les Rolling Stones et donc les
Beatles c'est les Rolling Stones donc
sont des créatures de laboratoires qui
ont été créés à l'Institut Tavis
stocks historiques tous les problèmes
sont étudiés à fond
je pense que les téléspectateurs nous en
seront gré parce que vraiment alors le
Titanic n'a jamais coulé donc le
capitaine est sûr c'est très bizarre
parce que le capitaine était très mal
noté 55 passagers dont le propriétaire
du bateau gippy Morgan ont annulé le
mariage en fait c'est une histoire
d'escroquerie à l'assurance voilà une
complexe histoire d'escroquerie à
l'assurance fac qui tient pas totalement
la route lorsqu'on étudie les rêves que
le reste jusqu'ici
et il y en a beaucoup qui sont un peu
délirantes mais certaines sont quand
même intéressant j'adore le livre de
Christophe il y a les Juifs viennent de
l'espace les Juifs sont des
extraterrestres Jésus a survécu à la
crucifixion la question c'est oui il
allait parce que là il y a une Argentine
le scoop du bouquin c'est Victor Hugo
s'est converti à vie alors ça je l'ai
trouvé sur un site islamique
Bladi.net et alors ça m'a beaucoup
intéressé et lorsqu'il était curieux
c'est que donc il dit ça il dit on a
caché la vérité dit le site Victor Hugo
il s'appelait Victor
aboubacre Hugo ça plaît bon ok moi je
veux bien donc mais alors il donne une
preuve et ils disent la preuve c'est un
livre d'Henri Guillemin qui s'appelait
Victor Hugo par lui-même où il est
révélé que Victor Hugo alors Henri
Guillemin est un historien Suisse un peu
controversé donc alors moi mon travail
c'est là où c'est passionnant j'ai
cherché partout les livres d'Henri
Guillemin j'ai réussi à les trouver j'ai
trouvé le livre la fameuse source de
Bladi.net et là j'ai cherché chercher
pas un mot sur le fait qu'il s'était
converti à l'islam mais le personnage
Mouloud Valjean ça nous aurait
un signe merci beaucoup merci Christophe
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu